- I gotta ask: how did you four survive?
- WE DON’T TALK ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED AT DIVISIONALS.
- Hey, babe, let's close your window.
- Don't you dareeeeee.
- Dad, get me out of here.
- [Yelling, commotion]
- Goddamn Jets.
- Goshdarn Jets.
- WHEN WE CRASH, IT’S IMPORTANT TO LEAD WITH YOUR HEAD.
- OK, not QUITE the game script.
- We need to eat the weak.
- Already?
- We just crashed.
- Why is everyone worried? Derrick will carry us all to safety.
- How did you all survive while I was gone?
- WEEEE.
- I decide where Gronk goes. Always.
- So Brady gets to have a shirtless outburst?
- I have a genius plan.
Aaron Donald, go do things!
- I’D STILL LOVE A JERSEY SWAP.
- Green 17!
- Uh, yikes. Not looking so good for Mike McDaniel.
- Sorry, the lance isn't quite ready.
- Yo, did we crash? Sorry, I don’t feel turbulence.
- ONCE AGAIN, I MUST THIN THE HERD.
- COMMON MISTAKE, BUT I’M A HUMAN MAN.
- Oh, Lord, what’s the conference round like?
- Welcome to your nightmare…
It's a Zac Trap, y'all!
- Ugh, how the f--k am I gonna spin this to McAfee on Tuesday?
- ALL HAIL...
Ok...let's see...uhh...
Mahomes.
- YAY!
They're in a better place now.
The Pro Bowl.
- Doing great, Big Mac. Just gotta keep flying thus bad boy down the—
- I'm going to run it into the ground.
- WAIT, NO!
- I stand by this as a good decision.